still Knight G6 Rook H3 ideas how do you
fight against R H3 I think it's over
it's over because if you go Rook H1
Knight G6 King H5 Rook three and that's
handshakes mate was inevitable wow our
congratulations to to Sam but we're
going to go to the Fabby game as oh and
the players are playing with two seconds
on the clock so o somebody just want
check checkmate Wesley blundered a rook
with the last move of the game he
blundered a full rook and resigned sorry
Ray Robson versus nepo it looks like
black young should be winning here yeah
Black's A2
Pawn oh there's a fork those tricky
Knights jumping all over and it's also
going to be a queen not just the L of
and both Fabi and Yan win and mvl loses